Trascrizione: Luca Mandotti
Revisore: Piero Cavallo
Questo posto, Ischia, da sempre
è un’isola felice
e Napoli, la mia unica vera radice.
Quando mi hanno chiesto di partecipare,
non potevo assolutamente dire di no.
Sono veramente onorata
di essere qui con tutti voi,
di vedervi interessati
al nostro bellissimo e complicato
Mar Mediterraneo.
Come sentito dal mio accento,
sono nata a Reggio Emilia,
ma entrambi
i miei genitori sono napoletani,
e questa cosa per lungo tempo
mi ha fatto sentire di non appartenere
né a Reggio Emilia né a Napoli.
Quando ho conosciuto
il termine “Napolide” di Erri De Luca
avrei tantissimo voluto dirlo
di me stessa.
I “Napolidi” sono coloro che sono nati
a Napoli e poi l’hanno dovuta abbandonare
per qualche ragione,
senza mai abbandonarla nel cuore.
Ecco, io non l’abbandonerò mai nel cuore,
sarà per sempre casa.
Ma è soprattutto un luogo dove ho imparato
questo rapporto intrinseco fra donne
che poi è la traccia fondamentale
della mia ricerca fotografica
e potrei dire anche della mia stessa vita,
perché è qui che venivo spedita
tutte le estati dai miei genitori
a passare l’estate circondata
da tutto l’entourage,
specialmente femminile,
della mia famiglia.
E quindi fra mia madre,
le sue sorelle, le mie cugine,
a prendere questo rapporto
di costante cura e sinergia,
in cui tutte loro
riuscivano a essere fra di loro
contemporaneamente
madri, sorelle e figlia,
in un flusso così viscerale
che mi sembrava un tutt’uno
con il mare e la terra,
per cui mi chiedevo
se io sarei mai riuscita
a diventare come loro,
pur con questo senso di non appartenenza.
E alla fine questa irrequietezza
mi ha portato a viaggiare in altri posti,
in città molto grandi, metropoli,
grandi metropoli
dove poter incontrare
persone che, come me,
sentivano questo senso
di non appartenenza.
In fondo, se ci pensiamo,
nelle grandi metropoli
come alla fine è la stessa Napoli,
ci sono tantissime persone che sentono
questo senso di non appartenenza
ma è proprio lì che costruiscono
la loro definizione di casa.
E fra queste persone c’è una componente
molto importante, che è quella femminile,
che costituisce
la trasmigrazione femminile moderna.
Ecco, queste donne si trovano lontane
dalla propria casa,
dalla propria famiglia e dalla società,
dalla cultura di origine,
e si trovano a realizzarsi come individuo
in queste città che, insomma,
ci arrivano dopo essere state
nel loro luogo d’origine.
E, quindi, in qualche modo
sperimentano su di loro
quel concetto di “stanza tutta per sé”,
ovviamente in maniera figurata e moderna,
che descrive Virginia Woolf
nel suo saggio,
ovvero che una donna,
quando si trova sola con se stessa,
riesce finalmente a conoscersi,
libera dagli stereotipi,
lontana dalle aspettative
della famiglia e della società.
In questo modo riesce a realizzarsi
come individuo liberato.
E questa cosa porta ovviamente,
se la fanno tante donne
contemporaneamente?
Alla costruzione
di un nuovo immaginario collettivo
in cui riconoscersi
e quindi un immaginario collettivo
liberato dagli stereotipi.
Ora, se pensiamo alla storia delle donne
nel Mediterraneo,
non possiamo che ricordarci
che è una storia di migrazioni millenarie
e di resilienza costante.
In questo senso, diciamo,
la trasmigrazione femminile moderna
si inserisce assolutamente
come un continuum lineare
nella storia delle donne del Mediterraneo.
E ho una testimonianza diretta,
con cui vi voglio lasciare,
di tutto questo
di cui ho parlato, che è Amanta.
Amanta è di origini srilankesi
ed è nata a Napoli.
Amanta porta le sue origini,
le origini della sua madre terra,
elegantemente, nel suo aspetto,
pur con un accento napoletano perfetto.
Studia alla Federico II di Napoli
e Amanta rappresenta
il presente e il futuro di questa terra,
come tutte le altre sorelle
che quotidianamente lottano
anche fuori dalla propria stanza
per essere semplicemente sé stessa.
(Applausi)
Grazie.